you thought you were watching shopping
spree this is an educational course
this is masterclass and i need to get
paid hey this is eric dom and today
we're going on a shopping spree with gq
let's
go
hint
[Music]
[Music]
first category is musical instruments
i've been looking for some new sounds
please my ears
is that weird to say steinway grand
piano
at a very
very minimalistic price of one hundred
seventeen thousand eight hundred dollars
this magnificent six foot eleven inch
aka two hundred and eleven centimeter
grand piano is often referred to by
pianist as the perfect piano first of
all i don't own a home to put this thing
in like in this economy like who's
actually able to buy a house i don't
know if you like if you want to donate
one hit me up second i play piano
at a very elementary level so more than
this being like uh
look at me show off
it'd be like a hey it's a flex i put 120
grand into a piece of decoration for my
home that i don't yet have
got it who can relate next up stylophone
s1 pocket synthesizer
i don't know what this is this actually
looks like a torture weapon it's like
you press one of the things that someone
gets that is featured in the film baby
driver and you tap and slide on the keys
with the stylus to play and use the knob
to tune the stylophone or to create
pitch bend effects that's cool it's
affordable
it's economical a great stocking stuffer
slash i've never seen anything like it
it's intriguing do i know enough to make
a decision right now no i want to see
all my options this is a shopping spree
you're not going to pick the first thing
on whatever
spammy website you come across i'm not
calling you spam gq i'm just saying i
don't know who put this together i have
questions what is a style of phone next
up is a 25 string concert kayakum at
2300. oh the 25 string is an advanced
modified version of the original korean
kayak you can play both korean
traditional pieces and modern pieces and
this is handmade by a korean master okay
here's the difference between having a
massive steinway piano and having a
kayaking is you feel and you appear more
cultured in this day and age it's about
accepting and embracing all the cultures
and the differences and everybody wants
something i think a little more
localized shall we say
and a piano i don't want to call it 120
000 steinway basic
but
the argument can be made
that
it could be basic
most schools have a piano a lot of
shopping malls have a piano a lot of
hotel lobbies have a piano but which one
of those places has akayagum
64x performance chromatic harmonica at
679.99 i'm gonna say no because this is
just too long of a name if you need that
many words to describe what you are
doing and how you are doing it there's
something that is not connecting
on your marketing team this is going to
get lost in the algorithm
meaning i feel like the value could
depreciate significantly should we look
into the future
for investment potential also
harmonicas
freak me out and harmonica is anxiety in
a little
rectangle you can't breathe without
making a sound
so if you don't know what you're doing
you're messing up my ears i'm messing up
my own ears when i play a harmonica it's
high pitched it is confusing
it judges you for breathing
it makes me uncomfortable i know i have
unlimited infinite funds
but i'm gonna go with the kayaking
and this is not because
i'm korean this is because
kai gum it's gonna make you look smart
kyago won't judge you for breathing
harmonica will
next up entertainment we're gonna have a
little fun all right we got
atlanta hawks versus nyx at home in
atlanta floor seats at
4900. i don't think i no i've been to a
hawk's game in like high school and then
next we have
four hours of karaoke with three bottles
with up to 12 guests at maru karaoke
lounge in new york
for
110
this place looks nice this looks like a
futuristic
spaceship
with people singing and so happy they're
way too sober though in this photo very
misleading nobody's ever sober at
karaoke karaoke at maru karaoke i'm just
gonna go ahead and nix like karaoke is
fun but it's not worth
almost 1200 i'm a singer so i'm like i'm
good people are like let's go karaoke we
won't make you sing your songs that's
why i can't say
that's a lie they're like no no no no no
just sing mr brightside no no just sing
like a bts song
okay but like i accidentally slipped
four of your songs into it that's not
gonna happen dude and then you have to
listen to everybody else who's not a
good singer like come on you have to be
wasted to sit there and be like
good job
next we have a private performance by
john legend starting at a million
dollars there's nothing more romantic
than having your first dance with your
loved one to a live performance of all
of me the track that legend dedicated to
his wife chrissy teigen i'm a massive
john legend fan john legend i think was
like my first concert that i ever saw
with like
my own money as a high school student it
was like me
and three of my friends we paid like
probably 20 bucks to go downtown atlanta
to watch john legend with opening from
robin thicke who wasn't like massive at
the time it was at the tabernacle in
atlanta and it was a great show most
memorable show of my life arguably and
it was really cool though because i got
to play the tabernacle last year right
before the pandemic and it was like a
full circle
moment his song was the first song i
sang in korea
which pretty much started my career in
korea so
a lot of props john legend is never
going to watch this that's cool
whatever i'm gonna get a cameo at some
point vip coachella tickets weekend one
at one thousand one hundred thirty eight
dollars
if not more coachella tickets i heard
weekend two's better so i'm just gonna
pass on those then it comes down to john
legend and the hawks i don't want to
cause controversy but when it comes to
atlanta sports i know the braves just
won the world series but it's really
hard being atlanta sports fan being born
and raised there is heartbreak after
heartbreak after heartbreak i'm gonna
pass on that i'm gonna go with john
legend and i would love to meet john
legend i'd love to talk music with him
get his insight and like to hear him
sing
amazing so that's that's going to be my
answer there next up we're going to shop
for some new kicks
very important let's get some shoes roy
giant gator western boots at 895 dollars
that is
a very intense looking boot it's leather
i think i could wear this
maybe for a photo shoot with gq
which i'm manifesting into the world
hint hint
maybe on stage but also maybe not i'm
i'm curious to see what else is out
there could i pull off a style like this
hell yeah next one is camper twins
at 240 dollars
brown vegan tan leather shoes for men
100 rubber outsole
it was born in 88 same year as me and it
is a concept that
challenges the idea that shoes must be
identical they look pretty much
identical
so
you're really not challenging it that
much camper i look at these and the way
i would put these on is if i was living
in the pacific northwest and i was
wearing plaid with
you know some dark skinny jeans or if i
was living in brooklyn obviously i don't
love it next up vermont multicolor
reebok edition the masterpiece insta pup
sneakers 1190
which is on sale
from 24.80 that's like a whopping
20 20 discount low top painted mesh and
textile sneakers and multi-color cutouts
throughout round toe signature instapump
system at vamp
this looks like a museum just threw up
on shoes i feel like there's a great
collector's piece i i think it's
something i would collect i don't know
if i would wear it they look too nice
they look too you got to leave these
alone
and that's why nobody would buy them
because they want to not wear them
because they look too nice wait also my
math is horrible it's not 20 off it's 50
percent up it's more than fifty percent
off these shoes are more than fifty
percent off the original selling price
the msrp you wanna know why because
people aren't wearing these because they
look very in korean we say
important and distinguished and very
weighty in terms of how they should be
treated ooh
okay
next up is the north face gucci boot at
1490 the north face's mission for its
creations is to help adventurers make
physical discoveries but also discover
their self while doing so protect from
direct light heat and rain should it
become wet dry immediately with a soft
glass this is directly contradictory of
everything
that north face stands for
remember that time in like middle school
or high school where
everybody had a north face
yeah you remember everybody remember
yeah
the time is coming back when ebay first
became a thing and i really wanted a
north face and my parents were like
you're not buying like a couple hundred
dollar jacket
i found one on ebay and i got it and it
was like a defective piece or it was
fake i don't even like the color but as
a young kid you're like it's north face
like who cares just you just gotta rock
it get it put it on it's a little big
it's a little thin
it still says north face put your hands
in the pockets
why are there no pockets they all have
holes in them so my arms go straight
inside
i guess you could go hiking somewhere in
like
the alps or
whistler or tahoe or
wherever you go hiking but then be sure
to
protect from direct light heat and rain
aka put them on put a plastic bag over
them and try not to die while walking in
these but they look cool
they look hot all right so the shoe
summer i'm gonna go with the venom
reebok
masterpiece sneakers
because
it has the word masterpiece in it
next up is ceramics vase vaz
face
by seth a rogan at fifteen thousand
dollars the actor seth rogen the
proceeds of this will benefit the
vancouver art gallery hey this is pretty
cool i don't know what
or how he made that it looks like a
brain
like a double stacked brain
but it's cool a rockwood cigarette
dispenser at 2500 i don't really smoke
it's a cool thing to
look at but
yeah
it's not calling my name next up is
auto linger essence exclusive orange and
yellow espresso cup set at 265
earthenware clay cups and multi color
logo stamped at base these are cool cute
little espresso cups
these would i would actually just use i
drink espresso every single day very
practical and finally
it's at any leigh parker oh
floor lamp at ten thousand dollars okay
so we got four we got seth rogen vase
alta lingers essence espresso cup set
cigarette dispenser and the oh floor
lamp this is pretty easy for me i'm
gonna go with the floor lamp again we're
shopping for my house that doesn't exist
i think it would be a nice accent piece
is what they like to say right on these
home designing shows
and it's ten thousand dollars that i
don't have to shell out it's making use
of traditional craft from our past
with the slowness and and respectful
natural resources all included
sounds like a deal so thank you gq for
taking me on this incredible shopping
spree love spending your money and i
think i was pretty you know
reasonable with my purchases i'm not
breaking your bank i'm i'm a nice guy
thanks
bye and just in case john legend in case
you're watching this i just wanna say
i'm a fan and you have influenced my
music from when i was young in many ways
and it'd be an honor to to meet you one
day maybe work with you one day but
regardless i'm a fan thank you for what
you do
sir